panique chez les habitantes du manoir de
cluny à plateaux fou depuis deux
semaines elles sont terrorisés par la
présence d'un serpent dans leur immeuble
le reptile aurait déjà piqué une de
leurs voisines
ma voisine descendait de sa voiture
c'était le choix et elle a été piquée
par un serpent à cet endroit précis
elles pensent que l'animal a pénétré
dans l'immeuble grâce à phil ouverture
depuis ces femmes marchent avec des
bottes aux pieds et un bâton pour le
faire fuir
la présence du serpent a été confirmée
hier soir par le fils de carine du crès
[Musique]
depuis l'ascenseur a été condamné les
habitants sont obligés d'utiliser des
escaliers pour se déplacer la présence
de l'animal créé une véritable psychose
au sein de la résidence
le matin vous partez vous regardez sur
les voitures vous regardez dans la
cuvette de wc vous regardé partout donc
c'est pas normal on y va tous avec le
petit pot du pas racine petit produit
pas là puisque bon on sait que le soufre
ça éloigne les serpents ou les citrons
verts
l'alc allie donc en fait voilà on est
dans cet état là depuis au moins une
semaine
ne sachant pas où se trouve
on se trouve le reptile courageuse ces
femmes ne pense pas à déménager pour
l'instant mais elles se sentent bien
seuls complètement abandonnés à leur
sort